ladies and gentlemen
the ship has reached the shore
celebrations at the UN after 15 years of
negotiations its Ambassador for oceans
announces a deal
the U.N high seas treaty will designate
30 of the world's oceans as protected
areas by 2030 fishing and shipping lanes
will be restricted and more funding
provided for marine conservation this is
the treaty no one knew was really going
to land and last night it did and that's
a testament to really really hard work a
very dedicated individuals over an
unprecedented session this final one
that went over 48 hours so that's one I
I just want to celebrate and they're
sure there's hard work ahead an unclear
path there'll be speed bumps but we've
just had a really big win
only one percent of the world's
international waters is currently
protected most marine life is threatened
by climate change overfishing and
shipping activists describe this
agreement as a breakthrough and a sign
that in a divided World protecting
nature can triumph over geopolitics this
is an enormously important outcome for
for the world it provides
of opportunity for us to
to better energy and regulate
environmentally harmful activities in
the nearly half of the planet that falls
Beyond national jurisdiction the the
high seas this has implications for for
all of us all around the world
the treaty will now be studied by
lawyers and translated into the UN six
official languages before being formally
adopted Victoria gate and B Al Jazeera